this is landing zone oasis approximately
56 kilometres southwest of play cool the
date is 3 June and during the past 18
days of operation Paul Revere the 25th
Infantry Division lost three helicopters
to enemy fire during bitter battles with
a Vietcong in the central highlands area
the day traffic lightening troops are
standing by ready for another thrust at
the Vietnamese Communist a battery of
105's near the forward base landing
strip is firing a support mission
against suspected VC positions a few
kilometers away and begin preparing a
new landing zone for the next assault
below is objective alpha 10 where
operation Paul Revere will be continued
as as usual thick ground cover prevents
positive observation of the results of
the artillery barrage the observation
chopper however flies dangerously low to
have a look
narrowly avoiding an intercept with the
incoming artillery fire as soon as the
shelling from the 105 howitzer ceases
helicopter gunships move in to recognize
her by fire preparation of the landing
zone is thorough then the wave of
assault troops is airborne from Oasis as
the task force moves to the objective
on the ground at alpha 10 there is no
immediate contact with the enemy and the
tropic lightening troopers spread out
and begin a methodical sweep within the
past week the North Vietnamese 32nd and
33rd regiments have been encountered in
the fierce fighting in this sector of
the battlefront in these earlier
contacts 372 VC were killed while
friendly casualties remained light now
after a two-day lull in the action the
men of the task force are once more
boring into Vietcong hell jungle then it
happens
contact enemy fire from somewhere ahead
a trip flare is accidentally set off by
one of the men and the deep shadow of
the forest is suddenly brilliantly lit
the enemy breaks off contact and
withdraws moving from one dense jungle
patch to another the troopers press
forward pursuing the BC ambushers in the
dim recesses of the overgrown labyrinth
however the enemy escape every conflict
in sergeant rendevouz with a task force
along the jungle trail and reports an
unmapped village ahead it is located in
the foothills of the play panic mountain
the men spread out and proceed up the
winding trail in single file as they
move upward they pass some mountain
women with baskets strapped to their
backs but no Vietcong are seen as they
near the reported village the Tropic
lightning troopers come to an area where
the mountain people have been cutting
timber some of the cuttings look quite
fresh
in this maze of down timber the troops
set up a base of fire while other units
begin probing the village soon a suspect
is brought up the hill and is searched
and interrogated his belongings reveal
nothing another month and yard is
brought in for questioning
these tribesmen are quite primitive they
carry stone axes and weapons of wood in
their loincloth they seem quite friendly
and are willing stalkers in discussions
with several of the villagers
interrogators learned that the VC have
passed through the area during the past
two days
but that none are in the vicinity now
meanwhile back at the area base at Oasis
a helicopter brings Brigadier General
Glenn D Walker
assistant division commander to a
meeting with a brigade commander they
discuss their reported enemy division
headquarters in this area general Walker
is shown a russian-made SKS 7.62 rifle
captured during the fighting in recent
days the general also sees captured
enemy radio equipment demonstrated by a
sergeant
82 millimeter Chinese mortar shells are
shown and masher type grenade all are of
interest to technical intelligence
captured canteens web belts and
rucksacks are burned and destroyed after
examination here in the eardrum Valley
area operation Paul Revere continues
in another action involving troops of
the 25th Infantry Division films were
made on five and six June of Operation
Fort Smith in long-on province 64
kilometers south southeast of Saigon
these troops and Vietnamese police are
heading for the village of op bean some
of the vehicles have loudspeakers
mounted on them upon arrival at the
village the troopers find it's deserted
the villagers have fled the area every
house and building is deserted the
reasons for the strange behavior of the
residents is not clear to find out more
the troopers searched the area
thoroughly deep tunnels with hidden
entrances are found and some rather
unorthodox methods are used to examine
them there are no occupant explosive
charges are prepared and the tunnels are
then destroyed
some of the deeper more elaborate
diggings continue to smoke after the
explosions and the openings are watched
for any sign of life a search of the
dwellings reveals some to the Vietcong
homes and they are burned by the enemies
fully as the units move on a mine
destroys one of the vehicles blocking
the road removal operations begin
members of a security and assault
platoon immediately begin sweeping
operations to determine the location of
any additional mine however none are
found and the units move on realizing
the potential danger on this mission the
troops are alert to any signs of Viet
Cong booby traps along the way
they look for trip wires and other
hidden devices but none are encountered
reaching the next village
the infantryman and Vietnamese police
find the situation to be exactly as it
was at the previous Hamlet
they peer and probe everywhere looking
for hidden weapons only an old man and a
young girl remain in the village they
are questioned at length as to the
whereabouts of the residents but merely
say they have gone the infantrymen move
on and the operation continues
armie demolition experts confer on the
problem of blowing up Viet Cong tunnels
soil analysis crews of the 159th
engineer group take measurements to
determine the effectiveness of tunnel
blasting techniques the tunnels of
plagued Allied troops and could not be
destroyed effectively now a new method
of tunnel demolition using acetylene gas
on 25 May engineers of the 173rd
Airborne Brigade carry the new equipment
to blow tunnels during Operation
hardihood at Borya a tunnel entrance is
spotted the area around it is scanned
for other openings many of the tunnels
are vast intricate complexes extending
several hundred meters some are built on
three levels and are equipped with
underground rooms for storage of weapons
and military supplies the equipment for
generating and blowing the gas is set up
near the tunnel entrance an electrically
operated blasting cap is placed in the
tunnel opening
a smoke grenade is thrown inside then
the tunnel entrance is completely sealed
off and the area is carefully observed
for any traces of smoke from hidden
openings this gives the demolition team
an idea of the tunnels configuration the
new demolition method is simply to flood
the cave with volatile acetylene gas and
ignite the gas with the blasting cap the
resultant explosion will collapse the
tunnel a solution of calcium carbide and
water produces the gas in metal
containers the gas is introduced into
the tunnel through tubing a leak
produces an accidental explosion and
this man has to be washed down with
water now everything is set the blowers
push the gas into the tunnel and the gas
is detonated other tunnels in the area
are blown up the new technique of
destroying the vietcong tunnels does a
more thorough job of neutralizing them
than any of the previous method in the
woods northwest of Kushi a demolition
team with the 25th Infantry Division
will use the new method to blow up a
newly discovered Viet Cong cave
Brigadier General Edward H de saucer
assistant division commander 25th
Infantry confers with Major Jackie Maori
engineer officer on the use of the new
equipment for long tunnels several of
the acetylene gas units may be connected
together to produce more of the gas a
standard Army Mighty Mite blower is used
to spread the gas throughout the tunnel
destruction of the tunnels in this way
makes it unnecessary to risk casualties
by entering them for the purpose of
clearing out the VC
Memorial Day in Vietnam in front of
headquarters United States Army Vietnam
in taunton earth shortly before noon a
ceremony is held honoring the memory of
the American men and women who have
given their lives to preserve our
national ideals of freedom the services
begin as a chaplain delivers the
invocation Lieutenant General Jeannie
angler deputy commanding general of you
serve speaks briefly on the meaning of
this day and the sacrifices that members
of our armed forces have made throughout
America's history taps are sounded and
moments later the annual commemoration
of Memorial Day comes to an end
general Glen Dee Walker assistant
division commander of the 25th Infantry
Division is presented with tokens of
appreciation for his unit's help to the
people of South Vietnam handsomely made
by civilians in the area the gifts are
symbolic of the friendship felt by
freedom-loving Vietnamese for the
American fighting man gifts are also
presented to members of general Walker
staff by Vietnamese girls in traditional
dress a colorful ceremony and a welcome
one for the hard-fighting 25th
the base camp of the third Brigade 25th
Infantry Division at Pleiku is the scene
of hilarity as the USO brings over a new
show to entertain the troops TV and
nightclub performer big tiny little
heads up the act which features a combo
of top-notch players who know how to
take a tune for a ride and have fun
doing it
pop singer Mary petit goes over big with
the boys the USO provides two new shows
a month to play the Vietnam circuit plus
visits of famous stage and screen
personalities USO performers hurdle the
Vietcong ridden jungle in helicopters to
bring entertainment to our fighting
forces wherever they may be
next stop for the big tiny little show
Cam Ranh Bay
this is PFC Mike Baker US Army special
photographic detachment Pacific
reporting from the Army procurement
agency Japan in Yokohama the Army
procurement agency Japan is a unit of
the US Army Japan and is unique among
purchasing agencies as it combines all
the functions of procurement within one
activity here to explain the mission of
the agency is Colonel Evie Wow
commanding officer of the US Army
procurement agency Japan this agency
provides indigenous labor utilities and
supplies for the United States forces in
Japan this fulfills a need which cannot
be met by the military supply system
within the timeframe requirement the
agency's support then goes beyond US
Army Japan one of the units of
activities do you support we support the
United States Army Navy and Air Force
elements in Japan as well as those
elements throughout the western Pacific
we also support the military assistance
program in the western Pacific area the
army procurement agency Japan is unique
in that you maintain facilities not
normally found in one activity just what
are the other facilities colonel we have
legal talent financial management
assistance engineers inspectors and
price analysts to form a complete team
assisting the contracting officer in the
procurement operation division the
Quality Assurance division operates a
procurement test facility capable of
verification testing of chemical
electrical and physical properties these
tests ensure that the raw material and
end items meet quality standards set
forth in the contract the quality
assurance division approves and monitors
the contractors quality control as a
result of their modern controls and
capacity of production Japan now acts as
an extension of the u.s. supply system
to meet the immediate and extraordinary
needs of the army in Asia
this highway bridge 11 kilometers west
of Santo Domingo was undermined by
floodwaters on 28 May causing the center
section to collapse in response to
Dominican president Hector godõs
requests to establish an emergency
bridge across the Heine River the United
States flew in 795 thousand pounds of
bridge part in Air Force plane there
were 20 flights starting 3 June
complete power boats came in by air
matched level truck beds with rollers
facilitate handling to have a unit at
San Ysidro airport men of an engineer
company from Fort Benning set out for
the bridge site they convoy the first
sections of the m4 - t6 floating bridge
the pontoons are rapidly inflated
individuals sealed sections ensure
buoyancy should any one section fail the
inflated pontoons are then saddled with
a superstructure designed to bear the
roadbed the last portion is hammered
into place
as each section is completed it is
launched by the men u.s. army personnel
stationed in the Dominican Republic aid
in the actual construction of the bridge
starting at the riverbank metal sections
are laid to form the roadbed leading out
onto the pontoons they are designed to
interconnect in an alternating pattern
the boats flown in by c-130s are now at
work moving the bridge sections into
position enough sections must be
prepared and placed to span the 152
meter width of the river the bridge is
four point two metres wide and designed
to support 55 tons as the work
progresses word of the rapidly growing
bridge spreads throughout the
countryside a tower to handle guidelines
is erected the crane is used to raise
the wire cable to which each Ponton will
be attached by its own rope these
guidelines will give the bridge
stability during tropical storms and
changes in the river current this
emergency link in a vital Dominican
highway is a major gesture of goodwill
to the country the speed and scope of
the operation proves interesting - on
lookers on 6 June cars line up hours
ahead of time to be among the first to
cross over the bridge at 1500 hours the
official party with the inter-american
peace force commander general Braga
starts across the bridge which will
benefit the entire community
information is being collected for joint
ty us training and recognition manuals
the blue book of coastal vessels
Thailand field interrogation teams are
composed of Thai Navy officers and
civilian engineers ships like these in
the river have already been cataloged as
part of project a July
the program director is a US naval
officer from the office Secretary of
Defense Advanced Research Projects
Agency deputy project leader is an
American from the Battelle Memorial
Institute in Columbus Ohio the Gulf of
Thailand holds tens of thousands of
ships so important to the people in
nearby countries and yet so dangerous to
their military security miles of the
exposed coastline could be easily
infiltrated here engineers work with
their part of the questionnaire
photographs are shot the ship's main
characteristics are details such as
length overall beam measurements anchor
net capacity of hold and other
construction data the visit is made with
the permission of the ship's captain who
give statistics for the information form
to obtain data on the height of the mass
and Abney level is sighted it takes
about three hours to obtain the
necessary information on this size jump
to ties and aus information specialists
collate the data this book is the
outgrowth of an earlier junk Blue Book
of Vietnam the earlier book was prepared
to support stop and search operations
along the Vietnamese coast
the deputy director inspects the results
of the questions asked by the PI field
workers it is his job to coordinate and
edit the final published volume the
Bluebook of coastal vessels Thailand
in Bangkok Thailand major Emmett Sims
senior US army ordnance supply advisor
accompanies his counterpart in the Royal
Thai Army on an inspection tour this
ordnance Depot supplies class two and
class four items the manner in which
these are handled within the
installation is a particular concern to
the officers storage facilities of the
automotive supply section are also
carefully checked in this joint
inspection such cooperative efforts play
a large part in upgrading the efficiency
and effectiveness of the Royal Thai Army
Ordnance Depot's a maintenance company
in bongcheon also has a familiar visitor
captain Lee oj Piketty the US Army
automotive maintenance advisor here he
observes the changing of a motor in a
Toyota truck
captain Piketty also serves as the
adviser to another maintenance company
here in Bangkok this unit repairs
automotive assemblies turned in through
supply channels this mission requires
highly trained personnel efficient
organization and properly maintained
facilities to stimulate the achievement
of these goals
captain figgity maintains a close and
continually aise on with his Thai
counterpart his visits to observe and
comment on the unit's operations are an
important and productive part of his job
I am sergeant major Cooper airborne
liaison officer for mag Japan on May
22nd the first Airborne Brigade Japan
self-defense force celebrated their 15th
anniversary since its creation in 1952
as a 100 bang Kadri of the National
Police reserve the brigade has grown
into the strike force of the Japanese
self-defense forces organized with world
war ii equipment provided by the
military aid program the brigade is now
capable of making parachute assaults of
a battalion Combat Team sighs all of the
equipment here is built in Japan for the
self-defense forces it includes two and
a half ton trucks 105 millimeter
howitzers mechanical mules a new 7.62
millimeter light machine gun and this
Willa's Jeep built by Mitsubishi
industries under Rights purchased from
the US patent holder because of their
compatibility and accessibility these
jeeps and other Japanese produced
equipment have been procured for use by
the US Army in the Pacific and formapp
countries in Asia in this program 2274
officers and men attended one or more
army schools in the United States under
military aid program training Japan is
one of a very few countries which paid
for transportation of its personnel sent
to army schools under map training
Keystone in the compatible development
is the frequent and personal contact of
MAG personnel with our counterparts
contact is active at all levels between
the 33 members of the Army section of
MAG Japan and their counterparts
the medical regulating office or janroe
controls the movement of patients from
hospitals in Vietnam to other areas in
the western Pacific Command with me is
the assistant chief of general Far East
Air Force Captain Edward G can eyes'll
sir joint medical regulating means that
this is a tri-service activity does this
mean that you're regulated by the
Department of Defense you know the
Department of the Army is the executive
agency for medical regulating both with
overseas and in the United States we are
presently set up under sink pack as a
tri-service organization as of May of
1965 due to the Vietnam hostilities we
are assigned the US Army Medical Command
Japan for administrative and logistic
support our staff includes Army Navy and
Air Force representatives both officer
and enlisted captain Colonel would you
explain to us in brief what is medical
regulating we can trolla pate the flow
of patients from Vietnam to the
Mississippi command and within the
Pacific Command and from paccom to
Kaunas we control the patient's by
specialties directing them to
specialized treatment facilities the
object is to try and keep from
overloading a particular facility in
that specialty our objective is to try
and keep the military in hospitals of
their parent services today we have seen
what is behind the Swift and efficient
movement of patients from hospitals in
Vietnam to the other service hospitals
in the western Pacific general in its
performance of duty is helping to
fulfill the goal of medical evacuation
in that it is administratively
controlling the evacuation of patients
to provide for complete treatment
convalescence and return to duty of
Armed Forces personnel